yes they a lot about the people who work
at them my desk says I'm booked because
I'm Z to the S destiny unfortunately for
my girl Shauna her death screams earthy
hoarder but that's all about to change
Shauna has no idea I'm here to pin par
desk that's where my desk is crowded
with like nothing I kind of feel like I
have a lot of trinket I just don't like
to miss a time you know however
his love Shana we're here to pimp out
your desk shut up
you're lying I'm so serious you're so
lying so serious
where's exhibit all right Shana so you
are lying about your trinkets what
what's going on here with sufficient
little mirror yeah cuz I'm like I'm like
sitting there I'm like oh my god there's
something in my eye my contacts are
really dry you need Jesus
so which computer are we using here
what's happening you know I don't have a
good eyesight so you don't even know no
is what she felt with me no she got a
whole blender AAHA Dez what are you
planning on making I spend every year
trying to get my body right but it's
still taped but you know because I'm
just like yeah I'm moving some fruit
into my room you got these drawers
what's it girl
unacceptable okay it's that hot summer
it's sriracha I'm a writer and I love
music and I love a book I have a book
called Cape Verdean blue so I'm really
all about kind of like my culture and
talking about that all right cool
so Ryan you're in charge of Shawna's
made this tell me what do you have
planned for it we're gonna give Shana
all the things she needs
I mean her desk is a little messy it's a
little out there right now we're gonna
bring it all and give her a lot of
organizational space we're gonna have
pages of Shauna's book spread across the
top of her desk gonna laminate them
there cuz Shana likes to know what she's
got going on it's something to keep her
centered people focus so we're gonna
constantly remind her all the amazing
work she's doing trying to talked about
how she kind of can't see you she's got
bad eyesight so we're gonna blow all it
up and give her three monitors we I'm
gonna make sure she has the cake
black across all of those monitors which
we can always remember our home I'm
filling it so other than that I don't
want to learn how to DJ so underneath
the desk we're gonna have a turntable in
there so she can practice scratch and
stuff we're gonna have that and also
there's gonna be a microphone attached
to it so whenever she was feeling the
spirit so you can get up and give us a
live poetry in the office I like your
thinking I like your thinking
all right yes so rocky tell me what are
you gonna do with the left side of her
did so as it was there's a lot of stuff
on her desk and we're kind of having a
hard time compartmentalizing everything
so we decided to give her a second desk
why not get a little l-shaped thing
going on secondly we noticed that she
likes to get ready at work so we're
giving her a vanity mirror with lights
we're giving her three wigs and we're
giving her a drawer just for her makeup
cool I like it I'm feeling down on it
well fellas let's get this together
listing this over to art let's pimp out
Sean his death
[Music]
all right Shana yeah we got your desk
it was raggedy you had things everywhere
you had hot sauce and drawers up so you
ready to see your new desk let's go you
[ __ ] did this this is a [ __ ] book
alright Shana
so we hit you with three monitors here
you got a screen here and two screens on
the side cuz you know you can't see so
other than that we hit you with a
turntable and you got a microphone so
you can get up and do whatever poetry
you want to do at any time
speaking of poetry we also got your book
an early advance copy and we put some
pieces on here so you can always remind
yourself of who you are yeah so we got
all that and then I'm gonna toss it over
to rocky so he can show you the beauty
side but I just wanted you to know your
hair be a little dry so we got you three
new wigs to help you out whenever you
come in and it's just a little like
matte it you can just swap it out I
should don't Matt mmm-hmm I sit next to
you hi Rocky tell me what do you do with
her left out of this so we know you like
to come to work unprepared and prepare
edge the desk so we give you this
beautiful vanity mirror with lights
below it we have drawers for your makeup
and go ahead and check that out yeah
glasses then we got two these beautiful
three wigs we got your baby homemaker
we got your Niki and of course we have
your Rihanna yeah sure
you can see these these are
battery-powered lights it's crazy I'm
glad you like it
alright Shana we put up your desk we're
giving you a vanity a turntable a
microphone so you can settle people what
it is you've officially been pimped
[Music]
[Music]